hey 42 here it's safe to say most of us
have our body image hang ups these days
for some people it's acne for others
it's hair loss
some people worry they look old before
their time counting gray hairs and
trying to smooth out crow's feet whilst
others fear
exactly the opposite fearing people
won't take them seriously
because they can't yet grow a
magnificent and perfectly formed
mustache
which is of course absolutely true
mostly these are silly things they seem
like a big deal to us but in reality
we're the only ones who ever really
noticed them
but imagine for a moment that your body
image hang up was not some
inconsequential issue
like the slightest hint of moves when
you wear a tight t-shirt
but an overall appearance so frightening
that children burst into tears when they
look at you
and nuns cross themselves when passing
you in the street
because that was the fate of a man born
in leicester
in 1862 joseph carey merrick's
appearance
was so twisted and horrifying that he
still talked about
to this day more than 150 years later
and whilst his real name might not be
familiar to you
his stage name almost certainly will be
the elephant man believe it or not
joseph merrick actually came into this
world
as apparently healthier baby as any
other with no visible
signs of deformity or abnormality
whatsoever
and he stayed that way a happy normal
child
until just before his second birthday
when a strange bony lump appeared on his
head and his lips began to puff up
like he'd been given the world's first
and worst lip job
by the age of five the skin across his
whole body had started to become rough
and bumpy
turning a strange grayish colour his
right arm
seemed to be growing faster than his
left giving him a lopsided appearance
and his feet swelled almost beyond
recognition
becoming huge and club-like basically he
made quasimodo
look like miss universe so yeah the next
time you find yourself
staring in the mirror with one critical
eye on your
curdled complexion and the other on your
receding hairline
just remember compared to joseph merrick
you're basically a supermodel
anyone who's attended school anywhere in
the world will know that children
can be cruel little buggers and we can
only imagine the bullying joseph must
have endured at the hands of his peers
thanks to his increasingly monstrous
appearance
but he made the best of it sticking out
his lessons until the age of 13
which was normal for the time joseph was
very close to his mother
and it was she who got him through those
difficult early years
no matter what the other children said
or did
no matter how many people stared at him
or called him names
he knew his mum would be there to greet
him at the end of the day
a wide smile on her face that showed no
trace of the fear
and disgust everyone else treated him
with
his mother's name was mary and as well
as the standard bumper dose of love
mothers always have for their children
mary's was bolstered by a healthy chunk
of guilt
too after all her son's terrible
deformities
were all her fault or at least she
thought
they were you see during her pregnancy
joseph's mother had been frightened half
to death by a rampaging elephant
that had escaped from a travelling
circus she believed that intense fear
had imprinted itself on her unborn child
so that as he'd grown it had started to
show itself through physical deformities
it sounds like absolute nonsense and it
is
obviously but maternal impression
the idea that experiences during
pregnancy
can impact a child later in life was
widely accepted medical science at the
time
and most thought this was the reason for
joseph's remarkable appearance
whether through love guilt or a
combination of the two
joseph's mother managed to shield her
son from the worst a world had to offer
until she died of pneumonia that is when
joseph was just 11 years old
from that moment on his life became a
misery
his father didn't hang about in getting
himself a new wife
remarrying the very next year and
joseph's stepmother
was shall we say less than impressed
with her
newly acquired and seriously misshapen
son
by this time joseph's deformities had
grown even more extreme
his spine had begun to twist and the
growths on his head
had ballooned to frightening proportions
becoming so heavy
he could no longer sleep lying down for
fear of asphyxiating
instead having to get what rest he could
with his head propped on his knees
his lips flopped like the trunk of an
elephant
making eating a challenge and his speech
almost unintelligible
children in those days were expected to
pay their way
and at 13 joseph managed to find work
rolling cigars in a factory
not only could he now pay for his keep
but he also had the excuse to get out
the house
where he was mercilessly taunted by his
father and stepmother
unfortunately joseph's deformities were
showing no sign of slowing down
and within three years his right hand
had become so large and
twisted he no longer had the necessary
dexterity to roll cigars
desperate to make a living despite this
setback joseph managed to get a hawker's
license
entitling him to sell basic goods from
door to door
but yeah if ever there was a person
utterly unsuited to being a door-to-door
salesman
it was joseph merrick not only did he
have trouble walking
thanks to his bent spine and oversized
feet
but turning up on people's doorsteps
unannounced
in what looked like the world's most
terrifying and realistic halloween
costume
was only ever going to end one way with
a lot of screaming
you really do have to hand it to joseph
though it must have taken
incredible courage to go from house to
house
knowing exactly the reaction he was
going to get when the owner opens the
door
and unwilling to stay at home any longer
with parents who simply didn't want him
joseph ultimately ended up where so many
poor and desperate people did in
victorian england
the workhouse workhouses were originally
conceived as a kind of
welfare safety net for the have-nots
giving society's neediest individuals
food
and shelter in return for their labor
but in reality they were horrific
prison-like institutions
where conditions were squalored food was
little more than gruel
and the work was both never ending and
back-breaking
joseph would spend four brutal years in
the workhouse
his health deteriorating with each
passing month most people would have
probably given up at this point
but joseph was a fighter he decided he
wasn't going to spend the rest of his
days working his oversized fingers to
the bone
he was going to get himself out there no
matter what
if you've seen the david lynch film
about joseph merrick's life
simply titled the elephant man starring
john hurt
and anthony hopkins you may think you
know what happens next
joseph ends up as an act in a freak show
in london
he's caged beaten and considered nothing
more than an
animal by those who use his terrible
appearance
to line their own pockets but the real
story
was actually far more interesting and
inspiring
the elephant man was a great success on
its release in 1980
it was nominated for eight oscars and
though it didn't win any
it did lead to the creation of a brand
new award category
film critics were so outraged that john
hurt's remarkable transformation
into the grotesquely deformed shambling
elephant man
went unrecognized that the academy
introduced a new award the following
year
best makeup it's been a category ever
since
but whilst the elephant man is an
excellent film it turns out
david lynch's seminal work played
somewhat
fast and loose with the truth with more
than a few glaring errors cropping up
here and there in the script
not least the fact that they got the
main character's name wrong
he's called john throughout the film
portrays joseph
well john but will stick with the
correct name
as a victim exploited and mistreated
for the benefit of the evil men who put
him in their shows
but in reality he was anything but and
it was joseph himself who came up with
the idea
of becoming the star of attraction in a
freak show
as far as he was concerned if you've got
it flaunt it
even if it in this case happens to be
one of the most extravagantly deformed
anatomies in the history of mankind
joseph found himself an agent and he was
soon
touring central england as the elephant
man
the headline act in a brand new novelty
where he would appear in front of
ever-growing audiences who were equal
parts
amazed and disgusted by the sight of him
whilst i'm sure the reactions joseph got
from the public
were hard to bear it seems that
to him at least they were worth it
not only was he making a good living and
standing on his own two
club feet but outside of the shows
themselves
he was also getting his first taste of
what it meant to be
normal as the leading act in a freak
show
he was surrounded by people like him or
if not quite like him people who were
just as different as he was from
everyone else
the act was a success and soon enough
joseph was ready to try and make it big
in the capital
he secured the services of prominent
showman tom norman
who specialized in freak shows to act as
his manager in london
and boarded a train south full of
optimism
but things got off to a rocky starts the
first time he and norman met
with the showman so appalled by joseph's
appearance
he feared his new star attraction was
too freakish
even for a freak show which when you
think about it
is really saying something for this
reason they started small
showing joseph not on the stages of
grand theatres
but in the back of a shop on white
chapel road which is famous for its
multicultural restaurants
and for being worth bugger all in
monopoly but it turned out norman's
fears were unfounded people flocked from
all over the city to catch a glimpse of
the elephant man
with their own eyes and pretty soon
joseph was the biggest freak in town
in a good way as had been the case in
the midlands
he was an equal partner in the venture
meaning
he got to keep half the money they made
from ticket receipts
and an autobiographical pamphlet they
were selling
early merch basically although the shop
was small
and had a limited capacity it turned out
white chapel road was the perfect
location to exhibit the elephant man
because it happened to be directly
opposite london hospital
that meant as well as the regular
punters curious doctors and medical
students would frequently pop in
to have a look at the walking talking
medical marvel
inside one such doctor was frederick
treves
a famous surgeon who would later save
king edward vii from death by
appendicitis
who quickly became fascinated with the
elephant man
it's easy to guess from the pictures we
have what people must have thought of
joseph when they first saw him
but in trev's case we don't have to
guess
because he went to the trouble of noting
it down for us in great detail
in his words joseph was the most
disgusting specimen of humanity that i
have
ever seen at no time have i met with
such a degraded or perverted version of
a human being
as this lone figure displayed wow
don't sugarcoat it or anything freddy
but in the war between curiosity and
disgust that waged and treats his mind
that day
it was ultimately curiosity that won out
and he asked joseph to come over to the
hospital for a medical examination
the notes from the exam give us a sense
of just how deformed joseph had become
by this point
trees measured his head at 91
centimeters around
almost twice that of the average adult
man whilst also compiling a long list of
other deformities
including warty growths covering much of
his body
the largest of which gave off a foul
smell sagging skin that hung
like fleshy curtains and bone
deformities in the right arm
both legs and on the skull in fact
pretty much the only parts of joseph
that appeared in full working order
were his left arm and his penis and
scrotum
thanks to the freak show's success
joseph was able to save 50 pounds from
his earnings
that's the equivalent of almost 6 000
pounds today
it was a significant sum more than he'd
ever seen before in his life
and even more significant was the
freedom and confidence
it gave him joseph was now a self-made
man
living by his own means not held back by
his deformities
but actually profiting from them for a
short time
he was the king of novelty show in
london
but there was a problem on the horizon
his kingdom was about to come under
attack
had joseph being born 20 years earlier
he would have probably gone on to have a
long
and affluent career but towards the end
of the 19th century
sentiment towards freak shows across
victorian london
was changing and people were starting to
view them
not as wholesome fun for all the family
but
as distasteful exploitative and
morally corrupt as perhaps the most
famous
freak in the capital it wasn't long
before the police arrived to shut the
elephant man down
instead of searching for a new location
for his show joseph did what he always
did in difficult times
he made a bold decision it was time for
a european tour
a contact was found on the continent and
joseph set sail for belgium with money
in his pockets
and a bright future ahead of him little
did he know it
then within a matter of days he would
lose both
it quickly became apparent that public
sentiment towards freak shows
was just as unfavorable in europe as it
had been back home
and the elephant man did not go down
well with the locals
joseph's new manager soon became unhappy
with the situation
so unhappy in fact that instead of
working hard to try and turn things
around
he simply stole joseph's life savings
and kicked him out onto the street
it would have been dangerous and scary
for anyone
but for joseph it was catastrophic
he found himself alone and penniless on
the streets of brussels
a city he didn't know utterly unable to
communicate with the locals
who spoke no english not that it would
have made any difference if they had
when he approached strangers to ask for
help they either ran from him in horror
attacked him in fear or simply followed
him everywhere he went
in disgusted fascination but
somehow he managed to pawn off the few
possessions he still had left
to raise money for a ticket home the
journey was long
and complicated and joseph was hassled
and gawked at
every shambling step of the way as he
went from train to train
unable to sleep or even find a moment's
peace
when he finally made it to the port of
ostend in north west belgium
where he planned to take the ferry to
dover the captain of the ship
turned him away for fear he would
frighten the other passengers
joseph did eventually make it back to
london but
by then he'd changed he had no money
and no prospects and the small degree of
confidence he built up
in his chosen career as a novelty act
had been shattered
he was eventually found by the
authorities curled up in the corner of a
waiting room
at liverpool street station shaking
and alone the only thing he had on his
person was the business card
of frederick trees the doctor who'd
examined him
months earlier trees was called and
joseph was taken back to london hospital
where he was given rooms in the attic
medical professionals had been
fascinated by joseph's case
ever since trees first stumbled upon the
elephant man in a small shop on white
chapel road
yet even with the huge advances in
medical science we've seen
since to this day nobody has been able
to conclusively prove
what was wrong with joseph merrick the
extent of his deformities was so
great it's even been suggested they may
have been the result of multiple
disorders
acting on his ravaged body in tandem
but whatever afflicted poor joseph it's
fair to say
trees on his colleagues had absolutely
no idea what they were dealing with
and even less chance of actually
treating him which posed
something of a problem joseph had
nowhere to go
but if he couldn't be treated he had no
business staying at the hospital
in the end the hospital's chairman wrote
a pretty much unprecedented letter to
the times newspaper
asking the general public for help think
of it like an early gofundme campaign
the response was unexpectedly enormous
and enough money flooded in from wealthy
benefactors
touched by the story to pay for
permanent rooms at the hospital
for the rest of joseph's life but the
letter in the times had
another unexpected effect in one more
twist in joseph's remarkable life story
he suddenly found himself a celebrity
amongst london's high society
in time he was corresponding with famous
actresses
attending shows and visiting stately
homes in the south of england
the london elite couldn't get enough of
the elephant man his
charm and warmth was so at odds with his
monstrous outward appearance
he even had a brush with royalty when
the prince and princess of wales
he would be king and queen consort of
england a few years later
visited the hospital to officially open
two new buildings
princess alexandra personally requested
a meeting with joseph
where she shook his hand and sat with
him for a few hours
i'd love to say joseph merrick went on
to live a long and happy life in london
hospital
but once again just when things were
going well for him
happiness was snatched away and this
time
for good he died on the 11th of april
at the age of just 27. he was found
lying on his bed
the cause of death recorded as
asphyxiation
caused by pressure on his windpipe from
his oversized head
his deformities had finally beaten him
whilst a true story of the elephant man
is a sad one
it's also inspirational joseph merrick
was dealt
terrible hand after terrible hand in the
game of life
but all the same he never stopped
playing
and he even managed to win a few if
you'll forgive me for guessing a little
sentimental in this one
i'll leave you with a poem joseph
merrick used to include at the bottom of
his letters
just below his signature tis true my
form is something odd
but blaming me is blaming god could i
create myself a new
i would not fail in pleasing you if i
could reach from pole to
pole or grasp the ocean with a span
i would be measured by the soul the
mines the standard of the man
thanks for watching you can now buy my
new book sticker flag in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below
thank you